la page cinéma de ce dimanche avec la
sortie cette semaine d'un film événement
astérix aux jeux olympiques sort sur les
écrans mercredi le troisième volet est
plus qu'ambitieux 78 millions d'euros de
budget à la fiche clovis cornillac
benoît poelvoorde alain delon gérard
depardieu josé garcia mais aussi jamel
debbouze tony parker michael schumacher
de l'argent donc un casting
impressionnant mais un pari financier
risqué et comme toujours c'est la plèbe
qui tranchera marie-jo juan david
fossard ce nouvel opus gallo
gréco-romain c'est lui non pas la grande
route le petit belge d'équations benoît
poelvoorde tout comme clovis cornillac
nouvel astérix ou la grenade et yadin et
l'amoureux stéphane rousseau un canadien
chez les gaulois un poète
un baiser mais à tout prendre aux
caisses un serment enfin l'essentiel
après 16 grecs promis aux vainqueurs de
ces jeux olympiques en l'air des balles
à leur travail
revenons aux belges il répugne du nom de
religion prétendant la princesse grecque
et fils père fils et mal aimé le cesa
interprété par alain delon inattendue de
décider ce serait moi je représenterai
robe aux jeux olympiques qui croient à
l'abri point où tu es incapable de
représenter toi même c'est chaque fois
pareil et que moi j'irai tout titre dès
que ces petites ambitions tout cas ce qu
on va d'abord mon fils des milliers de
costumes et de décors justifiant parquet
un budget record de 78 millions d'euros
et la participation de stars espagnoles
italiennes ou allemandes permettent
d'impliquer ces pays européens
et du coup de demander à ces pays là de
d'investir massivement pour qu'on puisse
avoir un film qui effectivement rivalise
avec harry potter hier indiana jones
demain quant au couple mythique de
l'histoire ils retrouveront un souffle
nouveau avec l'arrivée d'un nouvel
astérix tout en énergie
j'ai illustré ses propos par les baisses
est ce que je t'ai demandé d'illustrer
mes propos par le geste
ben on lit entre un non-lieu entraîne
pas signature et entraîne toi peut
guérir
là je me suis vraiment inspiré des
dessins le semble du stade
au jt
du sang des perdants
on veut gagner les zones réflexes
mais sans jouer les gens vaniteux de
mauvaise foi méchant là je lé fais liant
paraissent tout ça j'adore sous 9
millions d'entrées pour le premier
astérix 15 millions pour le deuxième
la potion magique va-t-elle fonctionner
pour celui ci nommé - sorti mercredi et
comme chaque dimanche tous